i i had my hip and ankle done when i was  17. um and at that point i was also on  ssris for severe depression with  like hypomanic episodes so bipolar type  2.  um when i was 22 i was diagnosed with  idiopathic hypersomnia  which is just you're sleeping all the  time and we're not sure why  but i got put on adderall and  at that point i was on i was on seven  different medications my wrist  was extremely sore and i started getting  this blistering rash  and i was like okay i can do arthritis  i guess i can do bipolar i can do  hypersomnia but i cannot do  this rash on top of all of it it's too  much having a visible disease  is definitely worse than having an  invisible disease